okay that's better I started streaming
but I was connected to the wrong Wi-Fi
network and I don't think the stream
even started but now I think I'm live
connection looks good and Ivers I just
received one challenge but it's a
correspondence challenge with each
player having one day to make a move
I don't like correspondence chess just
because it requires like this daily
focus
I like rapid chess let's play this guy
the first challenger I wonder if he just
saw that I'm streaming and he's just
wanting to challenge me I don't know if
stream Labs is working there we go okay
so stream laps should be fixed
I'm playing a good player too let's play
let's play e5 mix up a little bit I'll
play some kind of alternative system
also I didn't have the chat opens so any
messages people sent since I've started
streaming I have not seen but if you're
here feel free to say hi I'll play a
Italian gioco piano whatever you call it
this is what I used to play during
childhood it brings back good memories
play the grub and Jeffrey CAI thanks for
being the first viewers let me know if
the audio is ok I was playing around
with some settings I no longer am using
my Yeti mic which isn't actually my mic
because a guy named Mike has it's but
I'm using my my Samson go mic which is
clipped on and I was making some weird
buzzing noise earlier but I think it's
fixed also hello to more people
Samsonite's been a while yeah long time
no see Samsonite's
what do I do here trying to remember if
I can allow like Bishop g5 I think the
standard move is just to play like d6
and then see what white does because if
he plays an early Bishop g5 then I can
expand with each six g5 and Castle
queenside so h3 it's kind of a timid
move but it's playable slow move I'm
gonna also play slowly I'm gonna play a
six actually
can I play this this is very common like
if I can get away with ninety five and
win the bishop pair that it makes sense
to go for it I think I can get away with
it cuz he hasn't played c3 sometimes
with no pawns on c3 he could take on f7
and wouldn't play b4 and then the
position could get really weird but in
this case I mean the the bishop can run
but it can't hide
I guess Bishop b5 c6 Bishop a4 b5
someday he'll have to retreat to b3 and
then I just trade off the Knights and
I'll have two bishops which is nice
noop noob was one of the only viewers
actually no one not one of the only but
one of the few viewers from my stream
earlier today which is a completely
failed stream where I attempted to edit
photos which basically put my my CPU
beyond its maximum capacity and I ended
the stream after like 10 to 15 minutes I
realized it was just too laggy okay so I
have the bishop pair the question is
what to do next
well c6 is very common probably now I
could castle I'm just gonna castle wait
he's gonna play Bishop e3 and trade off
the bishop also why is why is Lee chest
reconnecting
well my stream is live maybe Li chest is
going down
let's castle okay reconnected oh there
is a site updates people can't see this
I could zoom in and then scroll over
here no I don't want to do that there's
a thing that says site update completes
are they updating again it says
reconnecting again as long as it's not
my internet then I'm happy I can okay I
can read stuff in the chat aren't you a
lot of messages play games where I
blunder a piece and come back from
behind I did that another day it was
part of this challenge stream it was
interesting I'll take I'll take weird
challenges like that again
if you want to give me like a specific
challenge I'd be happy to do that messy
Marvin hello and hello to be x17
something something something okay audio
is good I'm not gonna do any more photo
editing at least for for this stream
unless you want me to that could really
slow things down
I know Bishop III is coming I'm gonna
play c6 because then if you play as
Bishop III maybe I have the option of
doing this stuff it could lose a seven
positions like this they could uh they
could lead to a long grind cake rats
good evening more like good night it's
so thin 11:14 p.m. buddy how's it going
yeah King Goldman been fine with
streaming with his wife I think they
were they're ending soon so I'm trying
to fill the void for the streamers who
are ending at some point also thanks for
the hosts Ghani Ches and Braden the auto
hosts twitch for fun hello and hello
Arman local hero I don't think I've seen
you before unless I have and just didn't
say hello this username young money swag
money eh oh yes my my username on twitch
is a double meaning which means if I if
I make it to GM I can still be I'm rosin
as an IM rather than I am so now he's
challenging my bishop giving me a taste
of my own medicine except I have c6
included so I can I can run and I can
hide question is do I want to spend so
much time moving my bishop I probably do
you might play Bishop d2 but then that
would Ryan let's do this okay Bishop d2
maybe a5 b5 and c3 could do you annoying
probably have to take and it's not the
end of the world take on d2 Wow
I take tea too maybe he wants to play f4
I would really love to get a Knight to
f4 problem is this queen is controlling
h5 so I could go for a g6 f4 we trade
and then then this Knight h5 move looks
reasonable because g3 is a weak Queen g5
could come his Knights are out of play
as rook is out of play let's play g6
feels wrong but and a few moves it
should probably feel rights I don't know
challenge soccer look for a pawn that's
impossible in this position might be
possible later on Fiona Chaddha
thanks for the auto host I think
everyone that I thinked is not here just
kind of sad but I'm thinking them in
spirits
armen local hero from chess bras I have
a chest bra story I play the Blitz
tournament today at the st. Louis chess
club it was like a actually a very
generous prize fund two thousand dollar
prize fund for seven rounds of blitz and
there were I was 12th seed there were
ten GM's yeah there were ten Jian's and
one of them was was Eric Hanson who I
played in the last round I got a really
good position but then I got nervous
because I'm playing just like an
internet celebrity and my time was
ticking down his time was also ticking
down and then somehow we got some crazy
time scramble and there was five minutes
no delay which is not a fun time control
unless you're really fast but I managed
to be slightly faster than him I flagged
him with with one second left it was
great what do I do here Queen g5 problem
with Queen g5 is Knight f3 so there's a
few different attacking resources here
like the Queen coming into one of these
squares the knight coming to f4 or this
pawn break with f5 I'm not sure if any
of these moves are effective they might
be effective in combination
I could also consider d5 do you find
looks enticing a5 might be the most
logical because my pieces want to be at
least my rook wants to be on the open
file or half open file and then maybe I
can sack the rook for the pawn
problem is he could take now if I take
back with rook or a bishop there's g4
can calculate or take out five g4 Queen
g5
it was very complex I mean I could also
just take the pawn and then that's a
very tense position I feel like maybe I
should just improve somehow maybe d5 or
Bishop e6 or King h8 even but he's
probably gonna play off for next I'm
gonna have to rely on intuition
calculating F for Ponte Ponte or f5
Ponte Ponte F for maybe Queen h4 my g7
you don't know hey dead man diem
thanks for the sub I'm also looking at
this idea which didn't cross my mind
earlier but to put the Queen on h6 I'm
gonna go for that
this looks more stable because I prevent
f4 I'm preparing to play off five and if
he plays mine f3 it just blocks as F
Khan which was annoying in some
variations where he could play off four
dozen g6 weaken the king arguably maybe
in bughouse g6 would be a terrible move
but the the thing about weakness and
chess is that a weakness is only weak if
the opponent can attack it this case
white has no strong attacking resources
against the Kings side okay so I saw
this coming that he might initiate this
Queen trade I could take and play
positionally I could play Queen g7 and
go for f5 later I don't want to play
Queen g7 being carrying the Queen now my
king is safe
I'm sorry play the Grob for auto mod
limiting your freedom of speech I'm not
sorry for the other guy though okay a
sevens attacked I could play b6 I could
play c5 play a six this is a moment
where being indecisive is probably a
very big weakness maybe be six or a six
alright just sack the pawn and play f5
play a six the structure is good against
a rook because then someday my bishop in
rook can be free and I won't have to
worry about the a pod again with this
slight update I'm not sure what's going
on also dead man thanks for subbing and
then following not too many people do
that
did Hansen rage no Hansen is actually a
very polite in person that might
surprise people but he's actually like a
genuinely nice person and like very
normal at least my interactions with him
yeah
anyway let's focus on the game d4 is
interesting I know how five my five
could still be played good take my
position actually looks very
questionable maybe I should have traded
Queens also dead man trying to distract
me when there's a critical moment going
on I'll read the comment once I make my
move but thank you for the 6000 bits and
I came out of nowhere
what do I do though if I take the pawn
my D pawn this week on the half-open
file
I can play fi that also looks weakening
and each house keeps updating this is
not the time
we'll play Bishop e6 sometimes a rule is
if you're not sure what to do then just
leave the tension
okay so dead man 6000 bits it's that's
so generous first time catching me live
oh I appreciate I appreciate the the
comments and kind words and thanks for
following yeah that's really nice
let me know if you if you want me to
stream at a particular time I'm always
open to getting feedback from people
Roque 5 was unexpected but it's a move I
think I have to play up 6 I could play B
5 but that weakens a 6 what else can i
play i could play rookie yates
my FF 4 could be a move to I went b2 in
some line I'm probably wait night afore
he just takes on you 5 and I'm moving
way too slowly I really don't want to
play f6
I have to play off six he's gonna play
g4 that's really bad because g4 it again
I'm losing a pawn
so maybe I'm just losing a pawn
regardless I could play b5 Roque one
Bishop c8 there has to be some like
better solution to this there is
increment in this game and this is rated
so trying to find I mean this is a
critical moment okay I have an idea I'm
gonna play off six because I I found a
response to g4
hopefully that was time well spent
yeah g4 i have Queen c7 very importance
clear the g7 square and attack the rook
and then I'll play Knight g7 and I'll be
somewhat somewhat holding things
together k Kretz likes late night
streams the problem late night streams
is that it's like really early morning
for Europeans so I I know there's a lot
of European viewers who watch when i
stream it like morning my time who
prefer more than nighttime but whatever
be x17 with the Ben Feingold Bowie moots
oh man
Oh Ben Feingold is Sol or it's not here
as you would um yeah he would punish me
or punish me with his puns okay so he's
thinking so I'm coming back on time
night g7 if I get night g7 and someday
96 and these squares could be accessible
and he's committed to g4
yeah okay I'm holding things together we
chess bleach us
what are you doing it keeps like
refreshing I don't know if it's a site
update or it it's just continuous
updates at least are improving their
codebase so there's at least some
benefit to that I'm trading rooks cuz
I'm scared or I'm allowing him to trade
rooks cos I just want to neutralize the
D file and now I want to bring the
Knight to f4 which might take some
preparation okay let's play 96 it's
trying to improve my bishop is really
depressed maybe you'll go for like c5
Bishop here in here to be careful though
maybe I'll play rook d6 first I just
want to take over the D file that's a
very common term attic idea to like
double up and the problem for him if he
takes on d6 I just take back and he
can't really fight for the d1 square a
rook to e3 okay so he's he's again using
my own medicine so we're probably gonna
trail a lot of things and then it's
gonna be a time scramble do i trade here
there's ninety four which is interesting
that probably just loses a pollen and c5
is interesting c5 looks playable yeah in
this sort of position I think I want my
pawns on Derek's race because I have a
LightSquared bishop so my pawns will
control the darks whereas my bishop will
control the light squares and then life
will be good also natcher nach sir
whatever your name is
thanks for the what did he just say it
disappeared thanks for the donation I
don't know if I can like the the text
was too small for me to read it
what is this g5
I could play 94 which is a purpose of
c-5 but there's a pin so I don't know if
that actually works
take-take-take that works right I have
to count I have to count quickly that
doesn't work
my e-pawn is kind of falling here take
take take I can take care or trading
stuff I'm so confused
rook d4 is also interesting I'm really
long time let's play Knight d4 try and
make him think also why is Lee just
lagging HS you don't do this so often
okay at least it registered my move this
is a time where I started ignoring the
chat actually this is a time where I
continue to ignore the chat just focus
on the game less than 20 seconds left
he's probably going to take care I take
here it's just a mess this my king is
safe pawn structure is slightly weak but
his King is also kind of exposed I have
three so useful move maybe h6 Queen e5
is coming then I think I have to take
it's not very pleasant least we're
simplifying I'm holding on to my pawns
I'll play h6 just keep surviving like
Fabiano
maybe I'll go for this because he has
lots of things on light squares
mmm h6 first giving my queen slightly
more mobility the key is when you're
below 10 seconds you have to stay calm
also now I'm almost below also messy
Marvin don't distract me but thanks for
the hundred bits ok let's do this
hopefully he moves his knight and runs
into Bishop c6 my pawns are defended
Bishop c6 will hurt him if not
physically it will hopefully hurt him
emotionally because now he's pinned and
now maybe this if a six I have this
what's going on there
this pawn can be weak wait we're about
to enter a King pawn ending I'm gonna
keep the pin he's completely tied down
and he has note like useful checks I
mean he could play you six oh my gosh I
almost flagged there he's still tied
down I should be winning this so this is
a completely winning King pawn ending
and I have increments let's play a
waiting move
it's all about opposition yeah I'm like
a 5 I have the opposition now oh let's
go this gonna be a little bit fancy
because I want to control G 3 so when
this doesn't have King G 3 he's trying
to dirty flag me but as long as Lee
chest doesn't update for too long it
should be just game over okay he's gonna
try this dirty stalemate Rick I'll play
b5 and now he has legal move one legal
move but okay somehow I survived that
under pressure no he was better like he
was he was playing really well too but
then he got pinned I knew that the
bishop on c6 was gonna hurt him
physically emotionally material-wise
alien is neck
Ilia are you still in the neighborhood
and would you like to be a guest on the
stream also congratulations Illya on
like winning money unlike most of us I'm
not I'm just unable to win money I have
to eat donated money it's still not too
bad that wasn't okay let's go back what
did he do wrong
he allowed Bishop c6 I thought this
position is very unpleasant for black
what he probably should have done is got
his knight to f6 but that may have
required some sort of cheating or some
sort of like magic trick cuz yeah Bishop
c6 comes wasn't so bad but he should
have removed his King from a light
square this was not the best setup Illya
says after Wednesday I don't know what
that means
not sure what Illya is referring to I'm
leaving town on Wednesday Wednesday is
the 29th right but then I'll probably be
back at some points a city like crash if
you want to subscribe to me there should
be wait a minute how did I do
subscribe I don't know if I have a sub
command I guess I don't have a sub
commands that's really strange I should
have a slip command
maybe supports there we go
yeah you can there's a link to like
subscribe you can also subscribe for
free if you have Amazon Prime
hello LaFave or I asked me if I want
yeah I asked you if you want to be a
guest now I asked you if you're still in
the neighborhood oh and you said after
Wednesday I see sometimes I lose track
of the context okay let's play someone
else wait a minute I can't see their
names I'm just going on this rating
graph or the the computer graph is
beautiful people can't see it though now
people can sort of see it so like this
is just his his life experience no this
is his happiness levels throughout the
game I think he was happy here and then
slightly sad and then just full out
depression
so what is the key moment oh yeah when
my bishop came to c6
yeah this is Bishop c6 those like the
the big inflection points okay
I've got lots of homework oh you're
still a student
I forgot that homework can exist in
people's lives
okay well condolences to Illya I'm gonna
zoom out there you go Illya if you need
help with your homework I think I i
studied what you're studying if I'm not
mistaken let's play someone else
Cassie Mayer I'm too indecisive where's
my phone where's my Siri clip-on mic is
not a great clip-on mic it's not
supposed to be clipped on hopefully I
didn't mess anything up if people can
still hear me okay you can just verify
that give me a random number between one
and six okay you know those trace I'm
playing this guy Ty Ty the nice guy zero
good luck Eric do you learn from any
particular Grandmaster matches I would
like to do the same
yeah one of the very first ways I
learned chess this was back like before
I even started playing tournaments I was
probably at weight I learned a new
opening today Bishop c4 I want to play
that there's a really cool opening I
want to play see if he goes into it yeah
before I even started playing
tournaments I I would just go through
games my my dad like have a book and
like we would just go to Starbucks and
like play through GM level games every
game was a different opening
try and find the name of the book I
think it was called 100 modern chess
brilliance ease let's play tonight's III
wait what's this reading mmm trying to
think what tricks do I know I'll play
Knight c3 I'm intentionally walking into
the center fork trick I've taught this
from the black perspective like this is
usually a good line for luck but but
there is some interesting nuance if
black plays and I take you for if black
doesn't play Knight to g4 then we'll
have some ooh okay so this is a whole
point lighting Castle here and then
after this trade there's actually some
interesting compensation for whites let
me find this book 100 modern chess
brilliance ease I think any book that
you can find with like with like
annotations that explain the moves of
high-level games can be very very useful
okay this is a this is a line the Queen
g5 I feel like I'm just gonna win back
the pawn and then we'll have a very Josh
type of position and I'll have to
somehow grind him down
tax you on Facebook
okay yeah Ilya if you're still watching
I'll reach out to you but you should you
should stop watching and do your
homework
try and be a good influence so two
people okay let's take this pawn and
we're gonna enter some very dry somewhat
symmetrical position mmm
let's do this allowing him to move the
bishop with a discovered attack Suge
Kapoor was just watching my challenge
accepted video that's cool I was gonna
do a similar theme for today but then I
kind of forgot got a little bit
distracted I'm gonna keep the pin this
feels wrong my queen seems like a big
target on e4 but it restricts a bishop
from developing normally and he can't
move he can really move either bishop so
I'm just trying to annoy him that's a
good move though so I was threatening
some move like Bishop g5 now he's
threatening to move this bishop I could
go crazy and take on f7 take on each
seven and then beat down a piece I could
take on b7 that looks like a free pawn
thank you
am i only doing five-minute games no
I'll do any time control people once I
currently have 11 pending challenges one
of which is crazy house hyper pilot but
yeah I'm just picking random numbers and
I'll probably do like these challenge
requests so basically if someone wants
me or wants to like propose some way I
have to win whether you want me to play
a particular opening or if you want me
to checkmate by only using nights like I
did last stream I'm open to accepting
like crazy challenges like that
also leet just keeps reconnecting how
does a 1385 know this line he might
watch my videos I show the Center for
trick on so many occasions see 6 mm well
my Queens not getting trapped it's just
kind of how to play I would like just to
complete development the problem is if I
develop this Bishop he has this in this
but then maybe in the very end I have
Bishop b3 so I'll set up a trap I'll
play Bishop f4 hoping for this in this
and the trap is a literal trap of the
rook where if he takes a B to pawn it
will be caged in Colorado X we played we
played you were +3 and then you choked
out so you want revenge it's not easy to
win a winning position God I'm very used
to getting losing positions and yeah
when you get the winning position you
still have to say focus nothing's a
given
Bishop f6 another free pawn didn't take
this so generous
among a Mincy money yes I met Matt in
person it's actually really cool like
being in st. Louis like people will
travel travel in from like all over the
country some cases all over the world
and then like people they all just meet
people who like watch my watch my
streams or my contents so it's really
cool to like just interact with with
viewers in person and then like all the
players who are playing like this this
tournament they're all like celebrities
and taking pictures and signing
autographs it's really cool environments
angelic Jake what's my Hebrew name don't
laugh but my Hebrew name is slow-mo
which when I found out I was like I
don't know I was eight or nine I was
just so disappointed such a I mean I'm
sure it means something reasonable but
doesn't sound like something reasonable
I can win our seven speaking of
reasonable
it's another free pawn I don't know if I
want to take with the Queen and Bishop
mmm let's take with that Queen and I'll
tack the Queen with the bishop and then
someday I'll go for this like I'm hoping
for something like Queen d2 so we can we
can just get this over with
the 6th night checkmate was beautiful
yeah I forgot to tweet it it gets it's
past the threshold to to throw out the
tweets g6 with a counter-attack it's
interesting know if I'm winning a piece
in any of these lines
I'm gonna confuse him
I would like to confuse him he's trying
to figure out the best way to confuse
him and in doing this I'm confusing
myself but that's life
okay let's play G G 3 H 3 let's play G 3
no that would be bad cuz I forget I want
a back rank made him but he would have
Bishop G in the end
ok so we're gonna get officer Cory
bishops I'm gonna put the bishop on d4
it's very very solid and then I'll
target the G pawn or the a pond or both
rookie 7 is coming I just have to make
sure not to get back rank needed my
second tournament ever the second round
I kid you not I was playing a four year
old like barely tall enough to like move
the pieces I took all of his pieces
except like one rook he back rank mated
me I was like 600 at the time it was
devastating so this is one of these
situations I'm gonna do this and when
his rook
no it's hard to get back cremated okay
my opponent only has it bishop I could
potentially make eight bishops he's
gonna win this pawn what a buzzkill
that's sad I mean this pawn my supply
he's gonna play Bishop b4 and I'm gonna
play f3
even though Ben Feingold told me never
to play this move and after Bishop do
you five I'll play c4 I'll win the pot
win it right away okay I'm not gonna be
obnoxious and promote - what is it
promote - six more bishops I could have
won his bishop okay let's take
there is a game it was very recently
with the Lila chess playing like another
engine and she was just like making the
ponents suffer it was so cruel okay let
me not still meet this guy I felt really
bad for it's a computer engine this
would be like an interesting like okay
let's see if I can find made into here
it's may than to exist the king has some
squares made into might actually exist
may than to can exist only if the King
moves to the square I wanted to okay
let's try this promote tonight this is I
think objectively the best move please
play King e6 please now I assume I think
because it's very complex
it's two legal moves I wanted to promote
to Bishop with meets well now if I like
if I promote on the side its stalemate
all right he still meets I can't even I
can't checkmate here okay so go for wait
I just tried to play Queen c6 I meant to
play this and then if he takes a night
then I'm eight okay
good game
Queen and c5 was made into queen c5 King
here
there's too many squares Akeem can move
- I think I did try to play Queen f8 to
the c6 slightly hallucinating
ok I can't say mission accomplished
because there is no mission nice I won
some weird opening was probably made in
four okay
a17 pending challenges give me a number
between one and 17 mm what a number alte
easy good luck
ten minute chests give me a challenge
someone give me a challenge and by
challenge I mean like tell me what I
should do in this game hopefully there's
some creative suggestions bird opening
okay we're playing the bird opening
Brooke sac for a pawn in the opening
okay for a pawn so I have to develop a
rook first and then sack it for a pawn
and then I'll play seriously good thing
this is casual I'm sorry to my opponent
I mean no disrespect but people in the
chat are telling me to do this
I'll sleep five one's not defended let's
attack on what pawn to take I'll tack in
the center for those of you who came to
see serious chess I will start taking
the game seriously after I play ripped
85 okay now I'm taking it seriously and
now it's about playing good moves and
not listening to anyone in the chat so I
have to defend the pawned probably g3
makes most sense like g3 Bishop g2
control the diagonal
that's a nice square mmm Knight f3 a
castle I'll just pretend that I I still
have a ricany one like rook on any one
doesn't do anything until much later in
the game anyway where are all these
emotes people being emo happy or maybe
it's just one person he 5 is a good move
blocks up material wants to open the
center I think I'll take and then go for
Bishop g2
I might even employ the double fee in
Quetta because when you employ the
double fee in Cairo your bishops control
all four squares combined yeah if you
can just stop spamming the chats I don't
usually like to give timeouts
but please Bishop g4 is kind of scary
yeah timeout b3 Bishop b2 I don't think
black has a threat here probably b3
Oh messy Marvin's here
I see Marvin knows what's up what's the
most aggressive opening in my opinion
the most aggressive for whiter for black
could try and answer both questions I
mean for whitey for I move one knee four
and Kings gambit Smith Mora some of
these like crazy gambit lines not
necessarily the most sound also Grand
Prix attack like Grand Prix attack is
one of the most controlled and one of
the most aggressive openings from the
black side I really like the Budapest
you just go for initiative right away
it's also relatively controlled if you
know what you're doing recently I've
been enjoying the staffer gambit which
is not sound but it's um it's very
trappy there's so many ways I can go
wrong it's an opening against efore
anyway that's double fianchetto budapest
isn't that aggressive you could play the
fagio war it's variation though with
after after E 5 the night goes to e4
rather than g4 again it's unsound but if
you want to get initiative from early on
it's one way to do so I could maybe
after this game I could show some lines
but no knee no needs more more like
traditional type opening but very
playable has some aggressive middle game
ideas so the Queen the queen is
defending both nights so in some
alternate universe the Queen would be
overworked but like if I capture one
night it would still defense other night
so the goal is to attack the Queen I
think the way to do that I think want to
play this move but I play Knight c3 I I
really don't want to trade nights
there's three ideas with this move I
deal one it's probably not coming up
anytime soon because it's not only five
idea - which is very playable an idea
three this is a reason why I sacrifice
my rook was to clear the a1 square
because a1 square for the Queen is just
so much more valuable than just having a
rook in the way so but do I want to play
Queen anyone immediately or do I want to
play this first might be five first
because already there's tactics like the
Queen is tied down and there might be
Knights e7 someday I mean I still want
to play Queen a1 because that was the
whole point of the rook sacrifice can't
wait for the streams finale is that a
challenge I don't think that's gonna
happen I would be a really good magic
trick though to demonstrate some magic
on stream so I used to be like I used to
be into magic at some point in my life
also is this just some oh no this is not
a monster threat
there's just pins potential pins all
over the place
thinking about c4 c4 could get me into
trouble because that allows 93
not sure what to do Queeny six is
actually relatively stable to play like
each three kick the bishop
like h3 Bishop h5 g4 there's already
Bishop h4 my King is stuck in a lot of
these lines okay I'll go for a queen a
one fancy move someday I want to work
but I have to be to be patient patience
is a virtue want you to make a video on
the dragon what kind of Dragon there's
many types of dragons I went to a sushi
place other day had a dragon roll
I was watching another stream and
someone was asking what my favorite
fruit is which is dragon fruits there's
also the dragon opening a dragon
variation of the Sicilian which is
actually very playable I could make a
video on that I have some interesting
ideas for black Cobra has issues in the
middle game get too ahead of yourself
yeah a lot of players I realized they
want to they just want to attack too
early sometimes you have to be patient
don't get ahead of yourself improve
prepare some sort of breakthrough
I don't know thanks for the follow
problem here
I can't apply that advice because I'm
down the rook I'm just stuck I just have
to avoid blundering I'm just trying to
keep the pressure thinking III is
reasonable what else to do I could play
like king d honking c1 and runaway which
might also be reasonable I think I might
actually go for that looks ridiculous I
think my king is safer on the Queen side
I do walk into a temporary pin okay
let's get away from the file and now
basically the point is I can expand on
the Kings side without any repercussions
because Bishop h4 would no longer be a
check he's playing very solidly he's
applying like this patients rule that I
just kind of explained maybe that was
bad timing on my parts unintentionally
gave my opponent some advice
deadman this is your first time using
twitch you already figured out how to
sum and give bits and follow it's
impressive
I think you can control the color
usually the colors are just random but I
think you have some control over it
not sure how though I want to play g4 I
have to be on constant lookout for
threats I'll start with g4 bishop g6 and
now
now maybe g5 way g5 could get messy
taketake wow that's a big mess okay
let's play g5 that was an unintentional
tactic like this is not my intention in
hindsight this seems like a genius idea
it's kicking the bishop back to g6
playing g5 removing this bishop so I can
win the night I kind of just stumbled
into this so this is nice
making him think there's no increment so
time is a factor what do I prefer
Chinese dragon
Sultan variation there's a very
particular variation I like but I don't
know the name of it it involves putting
the bishop on e6 if they don't play
Bishop c4 if they play Bishop c4 and
then I like the line where you take on
d4 and play what's the move b5 like be
585 I'm taking this Knights okay so now
I'm just down the exchange
my king my king is a target here I'll
see this guy's uh
a tactical pro s a good thing is I have
a simple developing move which does so
many great things at once so that would
be nice yeah this was kind of expected
he's attacking two things the good good
thing is that I can just do this C
choose a pawn but there's more important
things in life I just want to protect
the d2 pond that's some more more
important thing also I'm attacking the
bishop so there's some line where like
if he takes here maybe I can consider
taking here and this is going to cause
him to think a bit more which is also
good
do I have 17 F or I did not even
consider efore I probably should have
it's a fork it looks good I didn't
consider it that would have been a great
move
maybe there's some way for lack to
unravel but I should have seen it before
I was so fixated on playing G for cuz I
was expecting Bishop h5 anyway okay he
takes on c2 so now the problem is if I
take here he can take on b3 so he
basically has two threats which can be
defended with this move or this move and
Queen c3 just looks better let's play
Quincy three
and now it's a mess still down material
but this is a tax and this is awkward
Kiyomi
is back and I'm back with more puns it's
true
good to see you Kiyomi longtime mod one
of the first ever viewers to the stream
Bishop h6 I forgot the diagonal extended
this far what do I do
I want to chop the Knights but if I play
d3 that would be illegal I could play
this in this I can't draw arrows he
defended g7 - I didn't even see I was
attacking g7 what's going on I mean each
[ __ ] looks reasonable maybe King bee -
I don't know I'm so indecisive King bee
- yeah let's play h4
there are three ideas with h4 Knight g5
Bishop H 3 and H 5 and all of those are
tempo moves will make some kind of
threats I don't know if any of them are
like super strong but that's for him to
worry about any thoughts on how Magnus
is playing yeah Bobby seems informed but
like today was the first game Bobby
seemed in in real trouble
ok let me focus Bishop h3 ain't Bishop
each tree looks great it's a skewer if
he moves a bishop then the bishop is uh
would no longer be fully supporting the
Knights I could just take on that five
take on c2 so I think I'm winning more
material I could dig on c2 first he
takes on h3 let's just take on seats you
first I'm taking my time here cuz
there's a funny move Bishop to g7 Bishop
to g7 rip g1 but then he has f6 okay
let's let's take this material equal I
have two nights for a rook and a pawn
it's nice
so life is okay we're trading Queens
exactly what I want to see I want to
defend this pawn let's do this I
definitely downloaded a computer into my
brain
I'll take that as a compliment I think
someone was saying that about Fabiano
today like he got a worse position but
then he just started playing like a
computer there's great defense there is
an art to playing when you're down
material against like lowering the
player is where you keep the tension you
cut the losses okay my position was uh
was on the verge of falling apart that
had to keep things complicated Baku's
excited about a book that's exciting
okay so now my Knights will show their
dominance over the rooks and time is
still a factor
the thing about two nights is you have
to find like coordination they have to
work together as my old coach used to
say they have to talk to each other okay
so this night is playing a very good
role of defending this night is playing
a decent role of attacking I could have
won the h7 plum don't know why I didn't
do that
and sometimes in these endings you just
want to look for ways to make outposts
so that's why I play e4 I want this
square for a night and then I can just
restrict both his rooks 27 d3 I'm sure
d3 was a move at some points and last
but not least I would like to activate
this rook I'll probably start with this
go for more aggression and there might
be some mating ideas in 96 or at least
some forking ideas or mating and forking
ideas wait a minute may than three days
and three wait mating for one two three
I forgot rook aged seven four okay that
was a good good practice on I'm counting
to four okay a good game alt tags easy
CC however you say your name thanks for
the game I'm sorry to disrespect you in
the opening but I fell into some peer
pressure in the chats who's told me to
sack a rook for the pawn I think it was
messy Marvin who started it
yeah no one deserves this
but no I mean black play the like black
did everything right I put the pieces on
good squares rook t8 was very good I was
running away
b6 was slow he was probably like
listening to my mantra of how like you
should be patients but in this position
I think blacks should take more action I
don't know what I was scared of though
maybe some more useful move doubling up
Brooks and then later on okay I miss e4
which I should have seen it got
interesting around here
I think the knight should yeah the night
was a bit unstable it should move back
and when it moves back you're
threatening Knight a to which is a
really annoying threat and then I'm in
many cases tied down to d2
I was I thinking there's another idea
maybe f6 at some point to chase away the
bishop I have to retreat to a more
passive Square anyway he has black fell
victim to tactics tactics are my Savior
okay new game 15 pending challenges give
me a random number between 1 and 15 13
15 13 the keel Deadman
thanks for the hundred bits glad you're
having fun I'm having fun too I'm also
suffering from allergies so if I start
crying it's cuz my eyes are just
watering not from sadness though
well it's play my favorite hoping
someone was asking earlier about
aggressive openings okay he's not taking
the pawn so try and play yeah let's play
this opening this was a fun line 94
hopefully he doesn't know what he's
doing
this is one of the most aggressive ways
to meet the fried liver castling he's
playing very quickly I don't think a
sting is a the most accurate move but
it's a playable move but the good thing
is Bach has a great Center but my Queens
a bit of a target so let's go back my is
also angelic Jake my eyes are getting
worse I should I should get eyedrops I'd
be nice always play off six
oh my gosh I don't know like this
weather when it gets hot and it's
usually when things are in bloom
so apparently something is in bloom also
I forgot to I forgot to take another
ridiculous challenge I guess I just
wanted to show some kind of aggressive
opening so I'm trying to be aggressive
hey it paid off
yeah that night was kind of pinned to
the g2 pong just to show one trick drink
tea steam really helps t feels so far
away to go all the way downstairs boil
the water also it's a bit like hot
so maybe iced tea but iced tea doesn't
come with the steam this is a dilemma
anyway I want to show a nice trap for
any e4 e5 players out there who play
King's pawn is black okay so we reach
fried liver fried liver from a weird
move order but this line I play there's
a lot of people who will be inclined to
play D 6 and after d6 looks like white
is being tricky but black can just
ignore it and take up on white will be
very happy
achieving the fork this is where if it's
an over the board game you can just
start shaking your head
and make your opponent's or give your
opponent a false sense of security and
reluctantly play Queen c6 they'll take
the rook now you take the g2 pawn not
the bishop
pawns are sometimes more valuable than
bishops because once you get to this
position you smothered meats and this
has happened okay over 200 times on me
chess I've shown this before on stream
just for any new people here this is a
useful line to know from the black side
also from the white
side I was showing a student this
earlier today showing it from the white
side I was just testing him and he
walked into like something very similar
as whites I was showing him the best
move in this position for white is not
to play d6 but to play c3 which is
mentioned by Colorado good move and then
the next two moves are really confusing
okay the first move is logical from
black rather than moving the night black
should play d5 but then the next move
for white is it's it's hard to find if
you've never seen this before
good luck finding Bishop f1 best move in
the position it's actually logical once
you start thinking about it you keep the
tack of the pawn and the knight is
basically it's gonna vanish and white
will basically just win the b5 pawn with
check the reason why white doesn't play
Bishop d3 is because Bishop f5 is strong
so if you're playing this is black
there's lots of ways white can go wrong
and this is already very nice for black
so Bishop Athlon critical line and then
I think the best approach for lock is to
not move the knight but to
counter-attack to take the pawn and
counter tact another than g5 and then
there's some crazy variation get this
position and white should be better here
with accurate play but there is a
there's a game that Bobby Fischer played
and Fisher lost in like four more moves
as white Fisher Castle which is
reasonable like defending the pawn
shouldn't no this is a Simon
so Fisher was maybe not the most focused
okay Fischer played Queen f3 that looks
reasonable
attacking the Knights attacking the pawn
as opponent played Bishop b7 then
Fischer displayed the most attractive
move in the position sometimes this will
happen in Simon's where you just assume
your opponent is a fish and in this case
it looks great for whites it's writing
two different mates in one and then
Fischer's opponent played one more move
and Fischer just resigns either the next
move is simply incredible for a black
I've shown this in a st. Louis lecture
if anyone has watched that lecture let
me know in the chats curious to know who
you are
bow black to move in this position I
will allow people to give suggestions
maybe I've just stumped everyone
Rachel a know from South America from
Chile Queen's egg pawn no Queen's he2
there's okay you get a double check but
there there's no oh actually away King G
139 h3 mates but King g3 I don't think
it's gonna lead to anything good
uh only one person so far the Samer x9
f6 knife at six
yeah Queen JG - its it looks really
attractive because there's this
potential mates but King g3 and black
just is out of checks out of good checks
Knight f6 is a correct move this move
literally does like five different
things defends Yeates defends d7
threatens made in one threatens of
Bishop it was like a double discovered
check or discover it attack because
unlike clears the fifth-ranked and the
diagonal for the bishop and Bishop d5
the threats just so I need to trap the
Queen so if Y play is something like g3
vision of d5 just wins the Queen so
that's how you beat Fisher in 12 moves
anyway lemon chief hello and hello to
everyone else who I didn't say hello to
ah Johanna is Johanna watching shout-out
to Joanna first on how giving me
notifications on my phone
Joanna if you're in the chats hello
maybe she's not though okay uh 16
pending challenges give me a random
number between 1 and 16 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
doctor donkey I played doctor donkey
before I have not King walked to the
corner without castling oh so pissed for
pot sir knows what's up this is another
crazy challenge ok can you walk to the
corner without castling
and the next ok the next challenge is
mate wait may than 25 moves I feel bad
for doing this but I'm gonna do it
anyway the plan is to do this this and
then this but maybe not in that order
why a 6 obviously to play rook a 7 and
then walk the Kings at the corner King
safety first
I'm just okay
so again I'm sorry to the people who who
want to watch it like educational and
serious chess but some I don't know even
who it was someone wanted me to walk
they came to the corner so I'm doing
that first and then we'll have a serious
game so it's it's sort of like giving
some odds some handicap I'm trying to
make some kind of logic out of this well
I play a subscribers first you're Lee
chess is wins occasionally and you've
never played me okay I'll play angelic
Jake because he's a sub and he's making
me feel bad I'm achieving king-8 ooh but
he's trapped he's trapped the rook what
a good move okay so I've walked Hakeem
to the corner without castling but now
I'm down in the exchange a for good move
do I have to walk the King back to the
corner I technically lived on eight for
one move this is a really bad position I
mean I'm not developed I'm not in the
exchange my king doesn't doesn't even
feel safe maybe if I go back to aid and
put my Bishop on b7 it will feel safe
that's fine okay that's all I need
all caps to now the idea okay idea is to
fianchetto and it's actually some sort
of like Dragon Benoni structure walk the
King to h1 h1 is this way now I'm gonna
trade Queens if we trade Queens maybe I
can lock my king
walk my king to all the corners before
the game ends probably not
a five a five is a great move
great positional move the good thing
here is that he doesn't have a dark
spread bishop so he can't really check
me along this diagonal and that's what
I'll have to try and take advantage of
he's winning the pawn none of my pieces
are developed but it's time to develop
weight I'm also considering Bishop g4
with a counter attack now I'm gonna play
this first an idea is to control the
dark space so now he's up the exchange
and upon also add aviator thanks for the
sub I'm I might be allergic to subs
I have to sneeze but I can't sneeze it's
the worst feeling in life oh gosh I have
a problem where I I just can't I can't
physically sneeze in front of people and
even though there's no one here I know
there's people here virtually it's so
terrible
okay well I've achieved a double
fianchetto these bits do you separate
streams by theme hmm sometimes the
themed streams are usually when I'll
play a tournament whether it be like the
chess classical arena or chess Cobb
arena Kings recently it's been a lot of
like viewer challenge dreams we're all
somehow like create a theme afterwards
and like a lot of the YouTube videos I
publish of like the stream archive are
just titles I try and come up with that
encompass the games I play but I should
make an effort to do more than just
dreams what is going on his rook is
active he wants to win the e7 pawn like
if I played like that six he's gonna
take on e7 is this real life I play this
and he takes my f7 I play this I'm okay
with that I think
because if he keeps taking pawns then I
keep getting more half open files half
open files are they more valuable than
pawns I have to find out allergies are
getting worse
because as a night gets longer maybe I'm
just allergic to like till late nights
that make any sense
speaking of nights superfluous nights or
as Rex Sinquefield would say codepen Co
wait codependence yeah codependent
nights they depend on each other because
when this rook left lands on the f7 the
Knights defend each other that's a good
move though developing a piece and
attacking the 97 so usually in life when
they attack you you have three options
of course you could ignore you can
defend or you can counter-attack I think
I would like to counter-attack I'm
looking at this move
see legally able to castle he hasn't
moved his king or rook okay so I guess
the problem with this is he can castle
so maybe just Knights e5 because this is
a massive target on e4 and it's attacked
twice only defended once half-open files
against double isolate pawns are worth a
lot it's probably true
this isn't doubled or isolated it's kind
of backwards little pawn on f2 can't
move to f3 that's a good move it's a
very good move he defends upon and
prepares f3
[Music]
trying to like decipher what's going on
in this position I'm down to pawns and
the exchange yes my king is safe
93 is an option 93 I don't know all I
know wait a minute I was about to say
all I know is there's one open file that
the bishop controls c8 so what to do g4
or g5 g for that looks wrong I have a
brilliant idea I'm gonna play rook F
fades it looks like a slow and passive
move and just not what I want to do in
life but the idea is his rook is almost
trapped I guess running low on squares I
actually just want to play King v8 and
Knight g8 like two more passive moves by
the traps a rook and he's playing slow
so as long as he's not watching this
stream he will not see what's coming
ninety-eight monster threats of trapping
the rook and maybe winning back some
material
I don't know if you can stop night g8
like even if he's watching and he sees
he sees this arrow and knows what's
about to happen yeah he can't stop it so
he's gonna take on b7 which is a great
piece to lose because this bishop is
just such a bad piece it's not doing
anything and then I'll be happy
I'll only be down to pawns maybe I'll
have a 5 in the future or Bishop T 4 he
said he was listening is he watching
doctor donkey it's okay if he's
listening I like to say my threats which
can't be stopped because then it just
makes a opponent think for a longer
kingi - okay I would love to get a
knight to e3
let's start with 97 I'll go for a 5 B 4
and C before could think I have 93 he's
capable of playing like some strong
moose I have to defend
luckily for me as time is on my side and
before is now mine so now I'm only down
one pawn slowly but surely now I'm up at
night for a pawn that was a nice gift ok
dead man is asking is genuinely asking
for advice it seems like let's play this
tactics from where is there a list
myself how to reassess how to reassess
is a good book there's so many places to
study tactics from I mean the online
trainer is like chess I calmed Isaac's
train early chess puzzles chest tempo
are all good starting points there's
some books which offer set collections
which it might depend on your level I
can recommend a very good series of
books they're called chests EPS I
recommend them for like kids but they're
they're really useful for any level they
train great like pattern recognition and
they're a lot more popular in Europe but
they might be the reason why like people
from Europe are just better at chess
because they grew up with chest up so it
gives it like a very good foundation if
you want to find out more you just just
google chest steps I think the website
is like chess - steps dot something
knight take C - was illegal that's true
I didn't even realize yeah I was pinned
maybe I did realize Johanna tries
Johanna tries I gave you a shout outs
like 20 minutes ago and you weren't here
I said if Joanna's in the chat say hi
and you didn't say hi but thanks for the
bits Johanna appreciate it's also a nice
streamer
my computer is dying side to restart
that was unfortunate okay new game give
me a random number between oh thank you
dead man for the hundred bits 74 I only
have 17 pending challenges give me a
random number between 1 in 17 doesn't
let me finish my sentence
thanks for Africa for the one bit give
me a random number between 1 and 7 dr.
junkies
thanks for the thousand bits and good
game sorry I disrespected you in the
opening serie finally gave me a feasible
number yeah I'm really sorry for
disrespecting you ok one two three four
or five norm rocks good luck 1900 I'll
I'll take recommendations again I'll
give it some time throw a challenge at
me I'm reading the chat's triple pawns
on the same file on the same file can
triple pawns be on any other file I
don't think they can okay so I have to
get triple pawns it's the best way to do
that
trying to think
triple pawns on the same file no just
okay just triple pawns I don't have to
say on the same file turbo blondes in
the center are very difficult
the most common triple pawns are on the
C file or F file which I'm trying to
figure out what the opening is to go for
I guess you didn't say you didn't say
what I mean maybe I can give my opponent
triple pawns and that could work let's
play this maker the four Knights so I so
the goal is to win this game and get
triple pawns at some points which
actually shouldn't be too hard to do but
maybe it will if my opponent resists
also Kenji good to see you long time no
see Kiyomi was here earlier some some
new viewers a stream and some old
returning viewers for anyone who just
joined I'm trying to like pass a mission
of getting triple pawns
I was hoping for Bishop before then he
could take the plane I'd a four it's a
weird move essentially I just want to
give him the bishop hair
ochio me is still here okay nice to see
the Kay's okay
d6 I'm hoping for d6 cuz I'm take take
I could have Bishop e5 and then maybe
create something like that it's unlikely
though the difficult thing is that if I
want to create triple pawns for either
myself or my opponent it's going to
probably create a bad position for
myself which then might make it hard to
win but I guess that's part of the
challenge and yes I've played a match
against on dress it should be on youtube
but I play the match against him when I
was with a friend
I was basically like my friend was also
in the room and he's a chess player too
so we were kind of we're discussing the
position together it wasn't really a
formal match or anything anyway what to
do let's play c4 I've decided that I
want to give my opponent triple points
which I don't think who said the
challenge was it piss for pot sir with
the all-caps
who this is looking enticing
this could happen very soon I'm sacking
a pawn to give my opponent triple pawns
it's actually maybe not a bad positional
sacrifice this could actually wind up in
quadruple pawns uh Joanna you don't have
to Google triple pawns triple pawns are
simply three pawns on the same file so
if I take and he takes back that would
be triple pawns the problem is he could
take with the bishop and I don't want
that
so let's castle
yeah he probably knows what's up I don't
even know what to do I'm just playing
normal move he is resisting tick okay
well I know what I'm gonna do if he
takes one f3 take back with a pawn that
will multiply the chances because then
maybe someday he'll play f5 and like
there's this potential for triple pawns
that's annoying let's play King here I'm
getting ready for like this opening of
the G file dead man DM thanks for
watching also thanks for being so
generous this will be one way to achieve
triple pawns if he takes but that's just
a piece AK I want to sack a piece let's
play this it will happen eventually
maybe but he's like he's a good player
he's 1900 he plays more classical it
seems like he's still under a hundred
names in every category
yeah I'm not talking too soon
staying relatively controlled because I
might act too soon it might be too hard
to win but we'll see
I like the fact that he's thinking here
oh yeah I said I would play you but I
forgot I'm so sorry you just have to
make me feel bad again let's play Bishop
III I have very short-term memory when
it comes to people's comments it's like
I get so focused on the chess do I get
extra bonus points if if we both have
triple pawns that there's some scenarios
where that could be possible or
quadruple pawns it's funny cuz these
these are double pawns but there's pawns
on the JSON file so somehow both pawns
could like merge together there is some
potential for quadruple pawns okay he
wants to play f5 promise I can't really
force anything I could just go and try
and meet him it's one possibility I'll
play Queen h5 I'll triple his pawns and
I'll may have my age 7 it's so enticing
to take the bishop
because it brings another pond just
closer to this conglomerate of ponds
play Bishop D 555 like Queen age 5 play
Queen age 5 just going for meets f7 the
targets h7 is the bigger targets it
would be really interesting he just
allows me to meet him and then I'm I'm
in like this moral dilemma
do I made him or do I try and get triple
pawns when without playing any pieces in
the center that's interesting
I have so few forcing moves though maybe
there's some ideas
really not sure
no there's so many candidate moves here
because there's not like a major threat
that he has considering f4h for Bishop
d5 just know don't know how the triple
pawns are going to be possible
in Bishop c4 is the easiest way to get
triple pawns but then I would probably
lose so let's play h4 just what else do
you I'm keeping the tension I could have
taken on f7 - that was a move maybe c4
what does c4 let's play this actually c4
is you can move but I have a plan
I have a dream no I just have a plan the
plan is to take after I'm assuming he's
gonna take I don't know what he's
thinking about but I do see some
potential I mean he could just flag too
that would be unfortunate never so I've
never tried so hard in my life to get
triple pawns
the original okay the original plan was
rook c1 but now this is actually looking
more attractive because either these
pawns are doubling or these pawns could
end up tripling he's probably just
listening to everything I'm saying he's
waiting for me to reveal more secrets
he's running long time which is maybe
how a witness f6 f6
okay he's playing solidly he's playing
very solidly
he's just avoiding that why is he not
taking on d3 this is so frustrating
I think Oh for Queen h2 in g4 can't
believe I'm doing this
I mean he's just one capture away from
having triple pawns so anytime I want I
can just play Bishop c5 he'll take and
then I'll try a second let's play this
this is gonna be intense yes okay that's
what I wanted
now I move back now he has double pawns
on the D file which is maybe somehow
relevant I also have a time advantage
which is also relevant he's playing c5
I'm gonna play g4
what is this position I have not
captured a single pawn yet interesting
move
now I have double pawns it's probably
physically impossible for me to get
triple pawns at this point
okay yeah he's gonna flag here we go
free night yes triple pawns okay now
time to flag him
look at those triple pawns such monsters
let's take on each five actually maybe
I'll have some mating attack
two sets of double pawns
I'm forking upon and another pawn and
now I want to play h6 those pawns lived
very briefly I give him more triple
pawns tied you maybe this okay he Flags
well wasn't the most climactic game but
okay it happens for a move
it was literally just one move move 29
to 30 in triple bonds
thank you Kiyomi I feel satisfying okay
I'm not taking a random number because
I'm playing 10 plus 15 okay we'll play a
long game angelic Jake just because
you're you're a subscriber I mean the
I'm gonna go with one of the challenge
challenges which was mentioned earlier
oh he's a good player too but I'm not
gonna say what the challenge is
I'm just gonna say it was mentioned
earlier the challenge will be hidden
until further notice deadly inhale one
bit per pot three bits Thank You Debby
inhale
it could combine multiple challenges it
could just be one challenge have to wait
and see I mean you could guess what the
challenge is if you want or you could
just sit back and watch you think that I
have picked up on hell mate with it in
25 moves
I'd be interesting
hello Julian Julian Pro Lake Oh usually
I don't say people's full names but
that's literally your your user name how
did Julian do in the Blitz this is like
the first German I've ever played in
where I haven't played Julian I kept
sitting next to Julian like every game
so relieved I didn't have to play him
it's play b5 so it's like the main idea
of c6 is B 585 gain space on the
queenside
always play 981 oh yeah I watched that
lecture actually I'll always play 981
lecture
good lecture who did you beat in last
rounds so I was not focused on any other
game I was focused on taking down the
alternate Eric
the perk is not a challenge that perk is
Opie I like the perk look good opening
relatively stable safe King ah UV talk
shots yeah unfortunately if five points
did not win anything which is really sad
yeah I'm not saying the challenge
because I think it would be unfair if my
opponent like specifically took
advantage of me like knowing what the
challenge would be like I don't know the
later it gets the harder is to form
sentences I'm gonna just complete
development 1897
maybe someday go for a 5 or C 5 see if
I've actually walks into some nice nice
Benoni structure where usually if you
have a pawn chain and the bishop is
outside of the pawn chain the pawns work
together with the bishop to control
squares and then the other bishops happy
because all the pawns are in dark
squares is it so the the correct
pronunciation of perk is actually P R
it's the C is pronounced like a Z or
something like Queen c7 preparing c5
angelic Jake in the chats
oh I missed e4 he's he's over defending
it now being extra cautious sleeve there
should be seven what is perk perk is d6g
6 9 f6 it's very similar to King's
Indian but it's an opening against efore
that's related like the modern some of
these other like old Indian lines
okay so I have achieved c5 I've
succeeded in developing my pieces do it
for America
you can't spell America without Eric
so that's gratifying in some way anyway
there's tension lots of tension pollen
tension I've been expecting d5 where
he's gonna gain space maybe he'll
consider taking we'll see what happens
it's 15 setting second increments I
started the game with 10 minutes and now
I have over 11 minutes I am Eric wait
what Oh like I is like an interjection
ninja ninja is a new name oh it's like
ninja but like a guy ninja so ninja okay
interesting
so okay we've were trading now the file
is open I would love to like control the
file at some point I would love to get a
knight to d4 that would be my dream and
unleash my bishop of course
ah isn't there like a another streamer
by the name of ninja who I should
probably know about but I don't think I
would recognize is it just like just a
normal spelling of ninja I play rook th
first attack and then defend mm or 97
first we'll play 97 first feel like rook
da only helps them and now I defend that
I attack yeah ninja plays fortnight's
I don't play any other games unless it's
troughs play drops but I don't think
there's gonna be a universe where I'll
end up playing fortnight's but we'll see
yeah Queenie - good move 95 is one idea
but it loses this pawn so I should
probably over protect the pawn somehow I
can also go for this and target a for a
little bit conflicted here I'll go for
that
I don't know I'm very conflicted
actually let's start with this and see
what he does so I posted a video on
YouTube just a few days ago it was uh it
was a draw studio it was like one of the
streams I did like within the last week
and like the video is a lot more
successful than my chest videos like it
got like over five thousand views in a
couple days so I'm wondering if that
means I should just start making more
drops videos and less chest videos but
then some people comment on the video
that they were sad to see they see not
chess so not sure not sure what to make
of it I'm happy about this trade though
because I'm gonna take the a4 pawn and
now I have a this two-on-one majority so
there's some plans of of creating a
pasture I'm also attacking this Bishop
expecting the bishop to move
probably back to where it came from
Kiyomi with the Japanese III there is
one point in my life I was learning
Japanese for like a few weeks back when
cassettes were a thing had like a
cassette tape and the only thing I
remember is kami Chihuahua but other
than that I would like to like like to
learn a new language though I already
know some Spanish but something more
exotic ninja with the sub thanks ninja
appreciate the love I just start pushing
pawns I love just play rook e8 and then
start pushing like rooks are meant to go
behind pawns when you can push them
usually rooks
yeah Brooks are always strange in some
ways ninja or thanks for the follow to
because sometimes rooks should be on
open files or half open files away from
pawns but when the pawns are very strong
like this they need supports and the the
harmony is great for black with the
bishop contributes rooks contributes all
the focus is going to be on these
squares
I will say the challenge after the game
it is again I think okay some pretty
sure some people can figure it out but
maybe it will become clear later ah yes
a classic pushin baby song Japanese is
fun maybe what I should do
oh this would be genius if I ever end up
like planning a trip to Japan which I
might go to Japan soon like it's
actually very possible I'll go to Japan
in the next six months because I'll be
in the area
I might just want to learn Japanese and
then I can get Japanese lessons from
Japanese tutor and trade him for chess
lessons assuming Japanese tutor is who
he says he is and can tutor in Japanese
that would be great ah a three and for
those of you who don't know Japanese
tutor is another chess dreamer who does
like a lot of instructional content way
more instructive than this whatever this
is by I'm pretty sure he speaks Japanese
Oh also Kiyomi could teach me Japanese
too
that's also yeah that's also very true
if you're offering I have to figure out
how to identify if I actually want to
learn Japanese see what countries I'm
going to but I feel like I have to start
learning a different language before I
get too old or it just becomes way too
difficult so what did I'll throw this
into a translator translate these
Japanese characters oh so this is a
symbol for go but the the game drops is
a bit different than go even though it's
just played with like black and white
pieces they should still make Ali Ali go
site Lee co.org probably will never
happen l ignorant a am I happy are you
happy with Carlsen like happy with him
meaning has alternate meanings I mean
honestly I have to I'm actually more
friendly with Fabiano than Magnus so if
I had to cheer for someone
okay I'm gonna root for Fabiano but I'm
just happy to see that they're they're
playing like in a World Championship
match I mean number one number two in
the world American player it's gonna be
it's going to be fun to watch and it's
historic for chess so okay Queenie five
is one idea
I'm really sad why
oh he traded off bishops it's kind of
sad I'm thinking about being cadeau in
my queen which could take some work I
was about to say like this this and then
this that would hang a queen
maybe Quincy it the Queen's not at all
useful on c7 and there is I think
there's some serious plan of actually
putting the Queen on h8 which is not
part of the challenge it's just a useful
square like control the diagonal and
threaten today to Queen someday but
we'll see
every third move must be a capture check
that would be really interesting some of
these challenges though I I would have
to do against much lower rated players I
was like an opponent like this I don't
think that would I could ever work I see
Magnus make a comeback in Li chest tile
arena number four I was doing official
commentary for that titled arena on
behalf of we chess but mods reach out to
me wanting me to commentate rather than
play in the tournament which I was happy
to do so it's somewhere on YouTube it's
on the leach s YouTube channel but yes I
watched every second of that of that
moment it was pretty epic because no one
knew who who clever tactic but failed
was so it was very dramatic at the end
Queen d2 what is he doing
okay Queen eh eh probably makes no sense
so maybe Queen you know just put the
Queen on f6
in queenie 6 keeping my options open
pressurizing upon Queen h3 was a move
but I think that's all it is
I like being slightly more centralized
Eric bullying low rated plays I'm trying
to create entertainment I'm sorry if
it's bullying I don't mean to be a bully
but sometimes you just have to make
things more interesting and I I only
discovered like this this concept of
accepting challenges after watching Ben
Feingold stream because he was doing
this other day and it was entertaining
for me to watch so hopefully people are
being entertained queen D 4 check could
be coming Yates maybe I'll play rook t8
at some point not scared of two rooks
versus a queen my a pawn is so strong
forever it passed and defended ok I have
a question maybe I can just ask Siri how
do you say thank you in Japanese that's
right
arigato ok problem is if I were to learn
Japanese I don't think I would be able
to do the accent
arigato Gotham chests on the other hand
he can do a Japanese accidents
anyway okay he's thinking I will say
that if he Flags like in this position I
have already succeeded in the challenge
what was the last part of that that's
something else how do you say thank you
in Japanese go see imasu does that even
mean maybe that's like formal okay noxee
to defending a to think I can do this I
like my queen here and maybe someday
I'll play this in this angelic Jake
explaining his ideas he says my plan is
totally not going gonna work I don't
even know what his plan is I think the
plan was just to stop my plan which
isn't much of a plan what's his plan is
to do this and then this just shuffle
around his pieces forever until I made
him on each file
he expected Bishop to g4 ah he was
filing this pin mm interesting
yeah I'm more inclined about controlling
a1 attacking the bishop doing this stuff
so we'll see what happens
he's a long time like the 15 second
increment is going to become more useful
for him very soon did I say soon I meant
to say soon ends and ends are sometimes
difficult so dosia masu is basically
Polites
oh ass like formal yeah it's the same
thing I was learning some Czech when I
was in Prague and the word for thanks
and thank you is it's different took
some getting used to does he want to
play e55 might be a threats no play
worked yet
gozaimasu so the US silence interesting
I was not expecting to learn Japanese
while playing this game but maybe that
was a challenge maybe the challenge of
this game was to just become fluent in
Japanese by the end of its I'd be quite
an epic challenge is Johanna still here
Johanna I want to say something but if
you're not here then that would be sad
GM can t know GM can t wait a minute
wait a minute I don't know what happened
to my sunglasses I did a stream the
other day with sunglasses just in honor
of GM County and because the Sun was
like coming through the window at a very
bad angle and I had to protect my eyes
but I don't know what happened to my
sunglasses I would put them on just for
GM can't eat it's too late some other
time my opponent's about to flag like
he's in trouble there's a skewer
there's a pass pawn life is good GM
candy is a sub thanks for being a sub
we in here
okay I'm not used to the phrase yes the
yellow is sometimes hard to read my eyes
maybe I need sunglasses to read that I
just take on do you want and play a two
and just be promoting he's gonna play e5
in the end I Queen Oh we trade there's a
funny line where I take and play Queen B
- that could actually be reasonable the
problem is I don't know if there's a
threat maybe I'm threatening Queen take
b3 to think a little bit here Queen B to
I don't know a two
just as difficult sometimes befores
attacked too
wait so
maybe I'm just confusing myself yeah I'm
confusing myself he has 23 seconds so I
can afford to take some time here see
that coming from my opponent being upset
that I I see before his attacks I'm
gonna hold off from looking at the chat
because I don't want to be influenced by
people suggesting news I'm inclined just
to take on each undo you want and then
thinks more it's not the most exciting
approach there's also a line there's
actually a really interesting line but
it doesn't work I won't even mention it
I see another interesting idea
could potentially work very potentially
work I like this idea I'm not gonna say
it because a surprise value would be
very meaningful I know my opponent is
watching
hey in teep Joe thanks for the hundred
bits and things for the comments I hope
this is not to uneducated still
educational even though I'm I'm doing
very challenges but I do appreciate the
love so there's a line I'm calculating
here which is kind of holding me back I
just need my team to be on g8 everything
would be good
he's been frustrating
I could play kingi it immediately but
before it's still attacked that's the
problem
okay I'm going to just start playing
moves and make him play relatively
quickly I just want him to make it like
a decision here I'm hoping it'll create
some opportunity for me
Queeny - okay not sure if it was the
opportunity that I'm looking for but
let's see I would like to play a -
doesn't he just takes upon he wants to
play e5 clearly so let's play let's play
rock a5 just improving the rook I also
would like to play Bishop d7 and my rook
didn't want to be on this diagonal okay
no let's do this why couldn't play a2
because he has a battery with the Queen
and the rook unless I was missing
something really obvious just possible
but yeah the challenge the challenge is
still alive which also plays a role in
some cases okay if I was kind of
expected I'm gonna play Queen b6 check
Oh after the exchange on d1
Oh in this position because a two runs
and runs into e5 maybe I'm missing
something there ah maybe yeah I don't
know anyway have to focus on the
presence and not the past
hey - now maybe Bishop f5 now or Bishop
g4
okay I like Bishop like Bishop f5 just
starts
and there's some interesting tactics
like if he plays
I'm just waiting for him to move I'm not
gonna complete my sentence he was
waiting but I was gonna say if he plays
Bishop before I had a - but okay we're
okay - so if okay - the idea is to play
Bishop to be one think how a two is
coming this is great and that the pawn
in the bishop will be soul mates
I will explain the challenge after this
game is done there should be four I
think I can just take and Queenie three
life is so good
mahan bear panda says he assumes I can't
go for a promotion because of the
challenge which is not true if I can
promote all promotes and I'll
demonstrate that with this queen bee to
move
aha mmm let's play ok one
and okay maybe now I can reveal the
challenge because I think even if he
knows what's up there's no hope for
whites and yeah Kiyomi is paying
attention someone mentioned in the chat
earlier I think two at the very
beginning of the game which I didn't
want to make my opponent aware of but
the challenge was I was not moving a
piece to any of the center squares so
there were certain lines where like
obviously I saw the e4 pawn was hanging
in the opening but I couldn't take it
because I was following the challenge
and there were points throughout the
game where I was trying to I was drawing
plans of like putting my pieces in the
center but that would never come true oh
that was Raph Raqqah who made the
challenge interesting okay so the last
thing I have to worry about this is pawn
should be an easy pawn to catch
our oldest promotes
wait who wins the race okay let's play
defensively put their work on the C file
just have to pay attention for Center
squares yeah kudos sir Africa for
creating an interesting challenge
good game wins occasionally did not win
on this occasion yeah but I mean I could
go back and show some key moments of
where I wanted to move in the center but
couldn't move to the center I think this
is like probably the best opening to
play like when you play the peer it's
especially this line with c6 and b5
you're almost never putting pieces in
the center
unless 'if i mean e5 one idea it's
important like that my opponent doesn't
know what's going on otherwise he could
take advantage of its what she kind of
did unintentionally by playing knight b3
given i can't take on e4 and maybe he
could take advantage by like putting
pawns on e5 and d5 which would be really
annoying or just putting like four
pieces in the center which i be able to
take none of so anyway yeah like around
here i really wanted to play ninety five
and i was really happy about this trade
i think Brooke a1 is a strong move like
rook e1 defends upon and then I have to
defend this pawn I was gonna play Queen
b6
but then Y can start controlling the D
file I think White's just better
I think you might would like to get a
pawn to be three at some point but maybe
it's awkward for both of us because my
c-pawn is a constant watch his beep on
his own constant watch so there's a
question about 8 - at some points 30 so
in this position a - I wanted to play I
could have overlooked something if I
play a - right away he plays he 5 I
thought II five would is like a natural
move for a white - given first of all I
I I want to take on e5 but I can't if I
can take on e5 then yeah that's just
much better for black but if I can't
take on e5 I wanted to play I wanted to
play one Queen here but then you can
take and then it's just trading stuff I
essentially lose a pawn because I
promotes that's weird so like some
promotes and then after all said and
done
oh I wouldn't 5 points so I guess it's
just a fair trade okay yeah
so hopefully that makes sense to people
what about Queen c3 I was thinking yeah
I was also thinking about Queen B - at
some points this is why I wanted my King
on GA cuz he has these anointing checks
there's another moment -
yeah if Queen Queen c3 is possible
the problem is okay I guess I'm
threatening here I was gonna say the
problem is I don't have too many threats
you could play a move like rook deep to
but then maybe I play a - maybe there is
some other ways to execute that was
rated that was rated I gained three
points Wow okay I guess that's my reward
that was rated Wow okay thanks for the
game angelic Jake any other sub scribers
subs one more game it's 1:30
someone when someone just commented on
my on one of my recent YouTube videos
didn't know you streamed now so there's
still people that exist out there that
don't know I stream okay that's
interesting so I'm getting more and more
challenges which is slightly
overwhelming but I'm coping this guy's
been waiting forever I'm gonna play the
aviator he sobbed so another sub that I
can reward he's really fast
I have played him in ultra bullets he's
beating me twice what
okay but this is hyper bullet this is
also crazy house so let me focus get in
the zone okay some crazy house theory I
like my position already don't know why
I played rookie eights anticipating upon
at age six I'm gonna meet him though
look at this oh it's about to be double
checkmate except he's gonna take on g2
okay they'll have to somehow accomplish
something this feels so dirty oh that's
nice okay
good game deviator ultra that was rated
- I think um I think I'm top hundred in
crazy house what do I need to be to be
top hundred yeah I'm top under than
crazy house so exciting kill me eight
yeah probably not the best thing to
watch or try at home sorry for anyone
who I
like hurt your eyes or something but
anyway that was fun
craziness is always fun wonder if Yasir
Yasir sometimes I'll be on me chest and
then Yasser will be like playing crazy
house after Midnight's against stockfish
it's fun to watch close your eyes I have
one more challenge
everyone's challenging me to long time
controls I just want to play a quick
game I'm gonna play kingi one I'll take
one more challenge piss for pot sir you
can give me the last challenge you've
been giving me some good challenges
lately but let me know I'm waiting
anyone's free to give me a challenge or
just a mission for this game can be an
opening it could be it could be
something crazy
what's his rating whoa he's really good
at bullets what
she just undefeated
65 games so he's played a lot of casual
bullets so how did he get a rating of 60
or of 2,600 play f6 king f7 I'm not
gonna do that against someone who's 2600
in bullets okay I'll stop preparing
against him and I'll just play let's
play
oh he aborted the game too late yeah cuz
I'm curious like when it's a provisional
2600 rating it could be like Magnus or
it could just be I don't know if they
won the first few games okay
well I'm tired I'm really tired
I feel bad ending it but I think that
was a good stream I had some energy
I played blitz earlier today it was a
long day and now it's already tomorrow
it's 1:30 a.m. for those of you who
didn't watch anything or don't know
what's happening in the chest world
Fabiano played Magnus today in their
last classical game probably last game
before the World Championship so as a
eventful event to follow if that makes
any sense anyway I'm really tired I'm
looking for someone to raid I need
person exists
looking for people who are streaming but
everyone's hosting me so flattering
search for chess okay I might raid
someone if I can find someone but I'm
going to end it here so I'll see you
guys in the future bye